the clark county school district is
implementing new security measures for
the upcoming school year jeremy j ford
is live with more on how this affects
teachers
that's right this weekend teachers are
preparing for the new school year and
doing what they can to ensure the safety
of every student there are new security
policies in place including one entry
point at schools and no phone policy
where students can't access phones
during school hours and a bathroom
policy this is where students must turn
in cell phones before using the restroom
and earlier i spoke with teacher maria
zuniga who tells me how these changes
will affect her
classroom will affect my teaching i
won't have to be worrying about students
having their phones out having
headphones in and not paying attention
so i feel like it will make students a
lot more accountable for their learning
says
along with hiring more campus officers
and school administrators zuniga says
parents and students should know all new
policies are implemented to keep
students safe from ccsd jeremy j ford
live local now